le choléra a maintenant pris le pas sur
les problèmes alimentaires
l'épidémie est dans sa phase meurtrière
les camions de ramassage des victimes
n'arrête pas ce sont les soldats
français qui organise le sale boulot
une épreuve pourtant indispensable si
l'on veut éviter d'aggraver encore la
contamination
c'est décourageant parce que tous les
jours aux masses de corps et moi voilà
autant qu'ils reviennent le lendemain à
l'entrée de la base où sont installés
les français c'est un mouroir les
orphelins se comptent par dizaines
cette petite fille n'aura plus de mamans
demain mais si l'on reste ici c'est que
souvent les soldats de garde d'un
discrètement eau et nourriture
la base des français représente dans
cette odeur de mort
un espoir le message a été transmis de
bouche à oreille
souvent les barbelés sont franchies et
les enfants les plus cultes et passe
alors en zones riches ils y trouvent
toujours des biscuits de le propre même
si c'est contre le règlement les
sentinelles regarde de l'autre côté
de temps en temps les soldats sont
littéralement piégée que faire d'un tout
petit enfant qui arrive presque nu et
que la nuit froide va tuer eh bien on le
garde
quelques heures on nourrit malgré le
règlement il arrive qu'on craque même
quand on mesure un mètre 90 qu'on pèse
120 kg et que l'on ait du 6e régiment
étranger du génie
ces enfants là seront sans doute
préservé
l'un avec le pull du capitaine l'autre
le tee shirt d'un journaliste un autre
avec une couverture qui les a préservées
les froids comme aperture hakizimana où
sont tes parents sont morts ils partent
vers leur paulina vers l'espoir mais il
ya ceux qui ne peuvent pas bouger trop
faible normalement on ne prend ici que
des blessés mais ça n'est pas toujours
le cas
l'un d'eux a par exemple été retrouvé au
milieu des morts celui ci à deux pas de
la base pourquoi avez vous choisi de
soigner celui ci au milieu tant
d'enfants qui ont besoin
mais j'attends un tout petit peu de
votre émission non
sinon ces efforts paraissent bien vains
les c'est sûrement comme cela qu'au bout
du compte la vie va la vie doit
l'emporter